looking under sting it will wrap it up
yeah all right boys first this is Shawn
Rothwell support Shawn s row bruh get it
what up Tito what up Brandon cold your
corner what's up Andy got King under
sing it for you guys
true crime shows what do you think watch
that 441 blood uh first 48 is my [ __ ] is
it I always freak up for everybody else
it's pretty pretty easy you know I'm
saying
also they never finish that [ __ ] in 48
hours do they it's always like day seven
oh my god 48
no one ever failure forty-eight effort
they never figured out that fast was
like six months later no [ __ ] dude gotta
ruin the show and then they tell you
can't solve a crime after two days after
48 hours so they solving [ __ ] didn't
realize how also you realize how much
snitches help I can't do [ __ ] without
people snitching yeah they just go
around looking for snitches and
everybody always has the craziest
nicknames in there yeah they're like oh
we found squib allowed here Chris D'Elia
has one of my favorite jokes ever he
goes have you seen the first 48 it's a
show where they have 48 hours to find
the killer but really they have as much
time as they want that see that's
exactly what it is man months later
all right well [ __ ] dude it's the best
joke that's hilarious one of my other
favorites had is got Larry read whenever
I was first started doing comedy and he
was out on the circuit and he is this
old Polish guy and he'd be like they
tell me now that I answered a phone
during sex
Oh he goes my wife tells me never to
answer the phone during sex and he goes
but what if it's you call and that's
what he said
that gets it kid it was for Nick anyway
yeah I do body you guys a bunch of
[ __ ] future hate crime victims
probably
with the way your attitude is first 48
me omit first 48 me to mix it up to get
out of the south bro detective like oh I
remember when he saw one guy hit a stain
on his shirt and I remembered an episode
three seasons any [ __ ] drip part of a
food on his shirt in the episode I'm
like no crazy man that guy what is this
guy's is a true crime all day man right
now I'm on the Pyke's town murders man
or pike Stan I didn't read the title
that much I just clicked on it did you
ever watch cold case yeah but I've seen
every cold case dude I've seen every
missing person I've seen every
disappeared I've seen disappeared
deleted scene do you know what you see
you'll disappeared I've seen disappeared
repackaged as the missing I've seen what
happens with the case of Madeleine
McCann they got the baby
I've seen what else dude where's little
Gregory brother French they [ __ ] up
dude they [ __ ] stole that boy and
then somebody's lying
what else have I seen bro Elizabeth
Smart on smart I've seen everybody I've
seen the girl who goes to a Dane Cook
show her sister went to a Dane Cook some
went missing after Wyatt and disappeared
forever documentary I say you know I'll
just go on vacation she was dead yeah
she think I'm fake Asian dude with a
murderer that's what you call it but
yeah I love it man dark man it gets dark
yeah I'm sorry I brought it dark man
what a pain in my neck today I think
I've shingles bro I think it's my
grandmother gave me this shirt thank God
you can feel your neck no you know I'm
saying yes sure is nice what else you
got Tyler Illinois I think it I think
it's pretty even though we're some true
crime fans I love that you didn't name
any Brendan ah dude first 48 cold-case
files true detective true detective not
true detective I like all of you
nope but true crime though you need my
order sighs suck my dick I'm side there
do I look over 50 yeah no ass chin about
Law & Order I like real [ __ ] brother
yeah I want to smell the blood yeah I
want some real [ __ ] I want to see
[ __ ] Gary snitch on his best friend
then they're in the [ __ ] in the room
and they're both getting life yeah I
didn't mean I didn't mean to man yeah
dude it's some of the people out there
that I just can't believe people just
are murdering each other dude just go
home and chill out you can pause over
some random [ __ ] - yeah some of them I
like the seasonal ones right now I'm on
holiday homicide right now oh I like
that one
it's good but some of the actors are
just like just bad it's like if you
can't act like you're getting murdered
or whatever and then don't do it
do you like did you watch cops growing
up oh yeah cops is crazy I think it's
the long-running TV show of all time
cops estill watch they all do it it's
still pretty good
although it's a little weird when so
white captures a black guy and then the
camera cuts out and they're like he's
cool man we got mint Wragge it's pretty
beat up
very strange that's some of the earlier
work yeah the more recent work it's a
lot more yeah everybody's like nah he's
actually pretty cool man we just talked
to him and then he I guess he fell on
his face on the hood the car yeah the
first couple seasons it's just like
Oakland cool it's just a German Shepherd
chasing a black guy I feel like it was a
little bit much I felt like you know it
seemed like just a little like they
definitely have some more white
criminals you know yeah but they weren't
focused on him were there no but I'd
love to see him let the [ __ ] let one
of those German Shepherds loose on the
stock exchange floor and get some of
those [ __ ] you know taking
people oh yeah sick shout out the cops
each other they asked for a cigarette
every time they bout the snitch on the
other guy but they're always in
handcuffs really can't you figure I know
and they're always like this off me I
should Ronnie yep
Carrillo
she was Ronnie Ronnie usually has done a
crime and that goes that's all
ethnicities to Ronnie is also an Asian
name isn't it it is I like when they
break down though when they get busted
for like the seventh time off [ __ ]
good I was even involved in this no dude
we we literally saw you shoot that guy
in the face like [ __ ] nothing better and
then their life's over
that's like Donnie got 90 years in
prison and he's pretty crunk about it
just be on TV I love it when they get
like oh what's up Dante shot at mama
what's happening yeah bro you're going
to jail for 70 years that's right is
that the most so far this is gonna be
the most played episode gangster though
yeah
back off my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching